patty burger glasses you bet no he
doesn't like it on the ground is so
upset
hey guys how's it going so I got my
little baby this super sweet new couch I
mean can you even imagine like having
this couch as a human let's see it
coming out look she's not you want to be
picked up new couch your baby okay
you're sick what if we put your favorite
blanket up here now do you like it we're
back here we're home he's been learning
some tricks and I'm pretty excited about
it he learned Paul yesterday many
Montreat Oh does he want a treat not a
treat look at his little ice marks now
you have like a few little smart so you
wanna cheat look treats around my belly
treats on your bed oh did you get the
treats mat and get the treats the future
is is coming home the future is lazy
come on Wow what following your buck
hello it's me hey - Mitch - Mitch are
you my boyfriend are you my son have you
decided which do you want to be if you
want to be my son speak if you want to
do my boyfriend speak hahaha so I'm
gonna get to the point of this video
because I got this box and I was
supposed to do an unboxing of it I
opened it and it was delicious snacks in
it and I couldn't even fill I couldn't
even get my camera fast enough because I
already ate like five things out of it
and Jenna did one of these before it was
the greatest box so I opened it because
I was thinking that it was this mouse
pad that I ordered so I was real
freaking excited about the mouse pad but
then I opened it up and I realized there
were snacks in here and I had just got
home from a flight I am gonna meet a
bunch of them but this is a graze box so
basically what it is is a snack
subscription and if you guys know me
that's basically all I do is snack
basically all day long they said they
put together an assortment of grayza's
best please let us know what your
favorites are who's here who's your hey
I'm Sara he's a terrible our table
babies here
there's somebody here look at him
shaking his butt hello alright I just
wanna let you know what I'm done right
now
Maxon snacks on snacks no bro what is
that guy a some that yeah what is dude
wait wait wait well I remember I already
ate like five of them a chocolate and
berries yeah ate them baby these these
are not for puppies oh wait hold on I
thought I was in the discussion oh sorry
yet how do you feel about the man I
swear in the whole nother box
I mean I'll eat it honestly this is so
much cooler than the mousepad mat just
rip the box oh yeah oh wait these are
the ones that the berries and cream
strawberries and cream I'm losing my
mind all I read I was reading I was
actually quite fascinated it contains
eight snacks they can be delivered
weekly or bi-weekly they have no GMOs
artificial colors or flavors and trans
fats that's kind of insane actually
because everything is made not good for
you more you did you happy at your house
and I'm just eating my snacks
somebody call 9-1-1 my camera's not even
straight
my view where is he dude look at his new
couch I got him okay
he hates it well I like it I got it
that pre-orders haha why is it a museum
what what do you mean nothing it is like
a pet monkeys like my baby my baby like
baby don't like it you're going straight
up flatbed Hey well is that fancy so
since there's no GMOs and if that means
I can eat the whole box for dinner uh
yeah actually what it says I mean I'm
gonna get a free graze box there's a
link in the description guys can get a
free box and honestly I'm not even
joking
this is the best description ever
magazine subscription no thanks I want a
snack subscription I'm so beyond excited
right now anyway it's not the person how
are you
this is sorry I'm crunching really loud
yeah aren't you finish up me in every
chest don't add of them ketchup
yeah hey so what's up I want to get too
close
are you sick a little bit I think you
might have actually got my sickness Hey
look we should get the dogs from the
snacks no oh look like Santa Claus oh
wow
I heard you smell like pee yesterday oh
my gosh this poor dog
no he's big you haven't seen him in like
a week and a half baby it's one way two
days ago oh yeah you've dead okay never
mind he didn't grow that much of it one
day's the keys
he loves this little bed you know I
guess what he doesn't like his new couch
well did you show them the couch I did
why would you buy that it looks like
something you'd get at it's gonna look
so cute in the office for whenever we're
playing video games and he'll just sit
there like wow I didn't love a soft some
I just want that I can sleep in this bed
what I know this is actually this
company is a bed manufacturer like they
make mattresses make sense cuz the dog
likes it he does the dog knows what he
likes he was really bad today we were
walking on in Dana Monica and we
wouldn't be Apple Store and he was just
walking and just took the biggest poop
in Apple no before we went into the
Apple store it was like a promenade yes
people there yep yep was everybody
looking yeah well you're like why I was
like walking and I was like one stop it
was embarrassing it was very much I'm
running looking at you yeah they're like
that mom can't control her child we were
also trying to determine if he is my son
or if he's my boyfriend
what do you think based on keeping my
son I can have severe some definitely
last longer than that's true right sure
knee braces look how big all they're
coming in perfect he's a good pup
I love you so much my son he is my son
all right guys I'm gonna go you saw him
shot something I mean I forgot you told
me before I don't remember no no that's
okay
either way he's a very sweet little boy
um I hope you guys are enjoying vlogmas
I was called it beta oh crap but I don't
hold a vlog today alright I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go bye bye
I'm gonna go throw the camera secondly
go description if you guys don't use
your free grace box and I'll see you
guys later y'all baby
those are mommy's treats okay I'll see
you later
hi